good afternoon my name is Hans Laura
I'm the director of clinical development
and education at Roche Diagnostics and
I'm a member of the medical affairs
department good afternoon everybody and
I'm today I'm here to talk to you about
the universal definition of MI and how
this universal definition of mi relates
to troponin the subtitle is clearing the
confusion and the reason why I'm saying
this one is looking at the customer base
who are using proponents in the real
world in the clinical practice there is
still although it has been now around
for a couple years still a lot of
questions still a lot of uncertainties
etcetera etcetera and so we saw the
value for this educational event my
disclosures is again as I said I'm a
employee of Roche Diagnostics I'm a
member of the medical affairs department
in the data here presented in this
presentation is purely educational and
is supposed to or is built on scientific
evidence based data in compliance with
FDA guidelines the program is in briefly
described is intended to review the
recent release of the third definition
of mi the new definition of mi has been
around for a couple years and we just
recently had the release of the third
universal definition of mi over some
updates it aims to familiarize
clinicians and laboratorians
of the implications for clinical
practice and we will focus on an
understanding of the use of proponents
in clinical practice briefly the
objectives of this presentation is to
describe key changes in the recent
released universal definition of mi
review the implications of an implement
of an elevated troponin examined the
clinical setting where a troponin level
or to measure a troponin level is
recommended analyze the prognostic
implication of
troponin elevations review non ischemic
conditions which can result in an
elevated troponin and finally discuss
the future clinical role for troponin
measurements and give a brief out
outlook of what might be coming now
briefly talking about the area of Scone
confusion here and now it's again some
details around the definition of MI the
definition of MI has become very complex
but also with this complexity much more
appropriate to the different options of
clinical settings in clinical practice a
very important question is how to
interpret the results a troponin used to
be many many years ago when it was a
positive component it was an indicator
for myocardial infarction not today
anymore
it is definitely still a very specific
indicator for myocardial necrosis or
myocardial injury but not any longer
only is it caused by a myocardial
infarction this is caused by or is the
result of the evolving a nature of
troponin si si
we have become much more precise became
today major concentrations we could not
in the past the thresholds over time
have evolved and still many people in
the field in clinical practice are using
everything from the 99th percentile
which is the recommendation of the
universal definition of mi but a good
portion of clinicians are still using
the who cut off and then anything in
between and last but not least it's
important to understand how a troponin
should be ordered in to Baden
appropriate ordering of troponin board
result in vs. and inappropriate although
the intentions can be good but it may
lead to unnecessary testing a brief
historical overview about
the defining myocardial infarction way
back in 1959 the definition was
developed where we looked initially at
clinical symptoms and changes in
myocardial necrosis markers were kind of
secondary criteria many years later we
started to use CKD ck-mb and it became
the standard the gold standard and was
used for the definition of MI to define
cardiac injury later with the release of
components the first troponin team from
Bruno Mannheim at this time and troponin
I from date baring they became approved
in the timeframe of 1994 to 1995 and
they started entering the clinical
practice field then in 2000 we started
redefining the way we are looking at
myocardial infarction that the troponin
became a centerpiece in this definition
and then in 2007 the global task force
further redefined the conditions for
myocardial infarctions and emphasized
different conditions which might lead to
myocardial infarction and then back in
2012 as mentioned before we finally got
the third definition of myocardial
infarction now briefly what is the
backbone of the third definition of mi
it identifies pathological
characteristics but all the other more
classical framework is carried forward
and I will talk about what I mean with
this it clearly endorses troponin now
has two preferred biomarker for the
specific category of myocardial
infarction which means here at the
troponin from a standard of gold
standard troponin has replaced ck-mb at
least as the guidelines are concerned or
as this consensus document is
sir the universal definition of mi
emphasizes that we have to see rise
inter ponens we have to see a pattern a
changing pattern
it requires rise or fall above the 99
percentile and while we are watching a
patient observing a patient at least one
level out of serial measurements should
be above the 99th percentile and then
again in relation of a rise in the fall
and the 99th percentile is also a very
important term now which has changed
over the last couple years as the essays
have become much more precise today we
can measure with sensitive assays
troponin in normal patients in troponin
is no longer at the marker for
myocardial infarction as I indicated
before but might be according to a lot
of data being published an indicator for
underlying cardiovascular disease over
time as patients eventually accumulate
damage troponin levels slowly arise and
we are getting to something we call
chronic elevations but I will talk about
this in a little bit further the my
universal definition of mi has also
looked into other things or into the
framework ischemia and necrosis they
have to be present in order to justify
calling the condition of the patient in
MI what is important is that we have
those two components
ischemia which is basically diagnosed
two clinical symptoms EKG changes and so
forth we can have some imaging evidence
for it but what is important here really
ischemia signs and symptoms of ischemia
are a clinical diagnosis where troponin
is not necessarily helpful
components come into play when we are
talking about necrosis when we are
talking about dying my Maya sites and a
here when both conditions the pinnacle
condition of ischemia and the causes
come together we are talking about an
acute myocardial infarction beside this
framework the universal definition of
them.i has further specified the areas
of sudden cardiac death
they have specified troponin elevations
or myocardial infarction after pci or
cabbage and are emphasizing some
pathological findings in the most recent
definition of MI the key points is here
what is the threshold for post-pc IM
eyes and the numbers moved up from three
times the 99th percentile to five times
for PCI and for cabbage from five times
the 99th percentile to ten times the
99th percentile and I would like to
emphasize here very clearly that these
are consensus threshold where I would
say experts are still discussing if
there are high enough and there are some
discussions that there might be even
higher so we need to keep this in mind
now moving forward I would like to
switch over the consideration I'm
presenting here and refer to the expert
consensus document as published by a
group of experts led by dr. Newby in
2012 I find this publication also very
helpful and insightful because it gives
us a nice structure how to look at
positive components as symbolized here
in this graphing one possibility for
example is we are looking at ischemic or
we are looking at your phone an
elevation in an ischemic environment and
I'm now trying to put an arrow
up which I stand right now so I will not
play with this further we have on the
left side in a light reddish color the
ischemic events on the right side we
have the non ischemic causes of troponin
elevations and ultimately down at the
bottom we have another box of analytical
considerations we have to think through
as we are looking at a troponin
elevation in general so allow me to
first then move to the ischemic part
again all starts with a troponin and
this troponin now is presenting itself
in an ischemic environment then we are
talking that we have the classical
definition of myocardial infarction
but with universal definition of an eye
we are now differentiating between two
types of myocardial infarction one is
the classical type the classical type in
the setting of what we call acute
coronary syndrome this is the classical
type of the STEMI the non-stemi
and we have then the condition of
unstable angina under a beaut coronary
syndrome where clearly the affero
sclerotic underlying disease is causing
the problem we have the ruptured plaque
causing the disruption of blood flow or
partial disruption of blood flow we have
the typical signs and symptoms of
ischemia and eventually necrosis so this
is the type 1 mi the ischemic module
myocardial infarction from this we are
differentiating now the type 2 on the
left side the non acs myocardial
infarction where we are dealing more
with the supply-demand
issue where the supply either is not
satisfying the demand for oxygen in the
heart muscle or or where we can have a
drop in blood pressure or anemia or
arrhythmia all conditions which are
leading to a condition
within their heart that the oxygen
supply is not sufficient to catch up
with the demand and this is now causing
a necrosis but what it has to be said
very clearly if we happen to Mir the
type 2 mi we wouldn't see blockage we
wouldn't see the rupture of a plug
because we have here a different
mechanism in place now the universal
definition of am i specifies also and
includes also categories for sudden
cardiac death but then there are the
procedure related types type for related
to a myocardial infarction secondary to
PCI enter type 5 cabbage related and I
made a reference before about the
different levels for PCI now 5 times
above or five times the 99th percentile
in cabbage 10 times the 99 percentile as
critical thresholds and as I was
referring before to confusion education
is here very important that we keep all
clinicians up to date about these
evolving recommendations these evolving
changes where again education is most
critical for people to keep up with what
is happening now then we are coming back
to ACS and want to focus a little bit on
for a little while on this to clarify
this ACS against describes clinical
signs and symptoms that evolve from
pathological process which then leads to
rupturing leads to a disruption in blood
flow we have the clinical signs and
symptoms they degree on or the impact of
the myocardium and impacted is it has an
impact on the degree of symptoms we are
seeing the severity of ischemia or as
ultimately an effect on the myocardial
necrosis and those terms this term of
acute coronary syndrome again include
unstable angina and BMI BMI part is
covered in the universal definition of M
I and here are the typical
terms of STEMI and non-stemi as most of
you are familiar with when we are
looking at troponin results in this
context we have here the classical
release criteria of troponin the pink or
the kind of purple color and the blue
color for chapolin I and T there is a
quick rise of the troponin results and
then over a period from 7 to 14 days
slowly the troponin C disappearing after
myocardial infarction but we have a very
large window where we do see clearly
troponin elevations for then many many
years we have the discussions about
other markers the role of CK CMB
myoglobin and so forth and as I said
before the universal definition of and I
clearly emphasizes that the troponin is
the gold standard and ask these tests
the troponin tests are becoming more
sensitive and we have in other parts of
the world I sensitivity tests
other markers like the myoglobin who
used to be the early markers or losing
of importance and are not as critical
anymore as the tests the troponin tests
are becoming more sensitive we are
seeing a quick arise in the troponin and
the troponin in general peak in a
timeframe of 24 hours within the
timeframe of the event
now some brief mentioning of the
different types of M is the type tool
especially up in the first picture we
have the type one where the ruptured
block where the rupture plaque is
disrupting the blood flow but as type 2
is more a demand and supply question we
can have spasms we can have
balance in blood supply these are
causing them can cause myocardial
infarctions in general myocardial
infarctions of type two are milder not
as severe as type one definitely not as
severe as the stem ease with complete
blockage but in general a milder and
clearly when we are looking into the
coronary arteries we don't see blockage
which we do see in type one mi so again
we had attached on all these components
positive proponent in all these
conditions from here we are now moving
to the white part of the graphic and I
will talk briefly about non ischemic
causes of troponin elevations and the
condition we have in these kind of cases
now again looking at the kinetics the
kinetic patterns of the release and
compare acute versus chronic in the
acute setting as I demonstrated before
we have this typical rise and fall after
myocardial infarction we have high
levels for several days while for a
typical chronic elevation like heart
failure we do have measurable components
eventually present in the patient
samples but as we are looking at them
over time we do not see dramatic changes
now here I want to emphasize another
point which I should have mentioned a
little earlier the universal definition
of MI requires a rise and fall but you
unfortunately we are not yet at that
level that there is a recommendation of
what rise and fall is required in order
to represent myocardial infarction
experts are discussing 20% 50% there is
a lot of discussions about what those
can be but again the guidelines are not
yet at the point where they are defining
definitions of deltas coming back to
chronic elevations
when they stay the same the print on the
right side on the blue part of the graph
was very small but we have conditions
here like chronic kidney disease heart
failure pulmonary embolism chemotherapy
associated cardio toxicity sepsis all
those can be conditions and these are
only a few of a long list of reasons
which can cause chronic elevations now
as we are looking at the probiotic
importance of those elevations here we
have depicted six different conditions
starting on the upper left side heart
failure then sepsis acute stroke
pulmonary edema noncardiac critical
patients of course operative vascular
surgery the point of this slide is that
whenever there is a troponin elevation
whenever there is a higher troponin
level it is bad news for the patient and
whatever graph you are looking here at
is when a troponin is elevated compared
to those patients with the same
condition who do not have similar
elevations the prognosis for this
patient is words so troponin elevations
in chronic conditions although not
rising or falling but staying relatively
stable do have organized tech
implications and the patient does worse
as we are looking forward the other
example is our renal disease and here
also detectable troponin are very common
and what is he here also depicted some
troponin eyes and the troponin t again
the message here is is really when we
are looking at no elevation or low
elevations versus higher elevations with
the red arrow patients do have the worse
prognosis so they are clinically
relevant and moving to the last part
which are some analytical considerations
here what is important are things like
heterophile antibodies human anti animal
antibodies rheumatoid factors or fibrin
interferences these are all coming
either from the patient or related to
the sample and not always does a
troponin elevation mean a chronic
underlying disease but we have also to
look at and ask ourselves the question
do we have those components those
analytical components causing those
interferences there are solutions out
there blocking agents or the package
inserts from the manufacturers have to
be specific about the specific
interferences so that laboratories are
aware if they are seeing results which
clinically cannot be explained that they
are looking for reasons what is can mean
on the analytical side now besides those
interfering vectors we also need to
consider something else which is the
variability between troponin results
although we are referring to troponin I
and troponin T each troponin of the
different opponent it's different
meaning an eye is not an eye so as
eventually we see a patient being
transferred from a different facility
into our facility we might see a
troponin result coming with them in
their electronic medical records or the
records they're having with them
comparing this then to the in-house
searched opponent there can be a
difference in results and this is due to
eventually the different methods being
used the different manufacturers the
different versions of a manufacturer
this is depicted here in this table with
a lot of detail but the cost for this
differences is really that we have
different antibodies binding to
different epitopes so they are measuring
everything slightly different and as a
result as we are looking at the 99th
percentile that is that point of our
reference population where that level of
troponin describes that 99 percent of
normal patients would be below this
point as you can look at those numbers
there are a lot of different numbers
representing that clinically the
differences are between those two
opponents which you can clearly then see
with the 99 differences in 99 percentile
values that the values cannot be
necessary directly compared now applying
the 99th percentile in putting this in
context of where have we come from on
this graph it's a nice graph which tries
to explain this
I was talking about with the increased
sensitivity of assays we can measure
troponin values in more and more normal
patients which are the normal population
is represented in green on the left side
of the graph while when in the past when
we looked at the whole definition we
measured troponin at relatively high
levels as essays became more sensitive
it took several years until we finally
reached the 99th percentile the 99th
percentile is now workers ended here as
the red bar at the upper end of the
normal population now ad as those assays
over time became more sensitive finally
the sensitivity is enough so that we can
now measure down to the 99th percentile
and below the reason I'm emphasizing
this one here is really that the world
hasn't changed in regards of troponin
very often
we are getting the feedback from
clinicians is you do measure two men
each opponents they are unreal there are
not they're representing the clinical
presentation of the patient the bad news
is there are real they can cause
confusions and it is important whenever
we are measuring a troponin and we
assure that this is not an analytical
artifact that we do explore what cause
is causing this rise so that we get an
understanding of what the underlying
conditions is if it is not an MI so if
we do deal with chronic elevations that
we do understand where those are coming
from that because it has important
implication for the patient now one last
important point with the universal
definition of them I am this is the
interpretation or this is the reference
to the precision and what I mean here is
as we have still all different types of
troponin tests on the market some of
them are very sensitive some others are
less sensitive I need to emphasize that
in the United States we have at this
point not an high sensitivity as a
approved yet they are some of them are
available in other parts of the world
but there is not a commercial si with
the designation of high sensitivity but
we have many contemporary assays some of
them help the title of more sensitive
sensitive ultra and so forth but they
are all as the experts are calling them
contemporary assays and the different
assays can have different precision in
the universal definition also reflects
on this they are saying the si should
have at at least as C be of less than
20% then it is acceptable ideal optimal
would be that they measure at the 99th
percentile at a velocity of less than
10%
but there is this wiggle room but the
guidelines are offering ideal again less
than 10% but clinically acceptable still
up to 20% of CV
now one final remark to the
interpretation of the troponin results
and I talked about there briefly in the
introduction about the appropriate and
inappropriate testing as we are looking
at when we should order troponin and the
expert paper makes this clear the
empiric really need to differentiate
between and it's a little small print at
the bottom we need to really
differentiate do we have a high-risk
patient or do we have a low-risk patient
if we have a high-risk patient which
could be that patient who has a typical
anginal symptoms or EKG changes or a
history of coronary artery disease if I
have an high-risk patient my pretest
probability is very high and with a high
pretest probability I do have with a
positive troponin then an high positive
predictive value and the higher the
positive predictive value for this
troponin is the less unnecessary workups
do I need to do if I have a high-risk
patient and the troponin is negative
there is a relatively high negative
predictive value a higher certainty now
I'm not saying that when a high-risk
patient comes into the emergency room
and has a troponin negative troponin
we're done now then is when the patient
needs to stay and we need to watch the
patient because there could be late or a
later release of components over time
but a the level of risk the pretest
likelihood from bio cordial infarction
is important for the interpretation of
troponin levels because if the risk is
low and the pretest probability can drop
slow-ass below 10% the meaning of a
positive troponin is completely
different we would have a low positive
predictive value meaning the ratio of a
true positive who helped the disease who
have a myocardial infarction compared to
those who don't is more unfavorable or
when a low-risk patient comes in with a
negative component what does this really
mean and what diagnostic implication
does it have down the road so pretest
probability am i ordering a troponin for
a high-risk patient versus for a
low-risk patient needs to be put in
context of my assessment of the patient
so the major challenge here in clinical
practice is often the inappropriate
ordering and what a meaning here is more
when we are having protocols in place
where every chest pain patient for
example might get a troponin and we do
have institutions where this is the case
under these conditions is really the
quality or the clinical quality of the
information provided by a troponin can
really suffer so an important thing we
need to keep in mind and an important
thing we need to educate people about so
as a result we have really a call to
action for the laboratory to reduce this
confusion it is really important to
facilitate the understanding of
proponents for the medical staff it is
important to look and inform about the
performance characteristics it's
important to really clarify the
thresholds being used and it's important
for people to understand for the people
who are dealing with the patient's
understand that we can have ischemic and
non ischemic elevations that we can have
acute elevations which have the tendency
to change there's a rise and fall and
the chronic elevations which stay
relatively stable over
little time but when we are establishing
the diagnosis of MI of course we are not
only diagnosing a condition
the next question immediately becomes
what are we going to do with the patient
and I will talk now about those clinical
implications scary car doctor scary car
a couple years ago proposed a scheme
like this and he looked at what is the
role of a marker in general in the
diagnosis where the goal is ready to
identify a disease and differentiate
from non disease patients here the
troponin in this context answers the
question or in context of ACS answers
the questions do I have type 1 or type 2
mi in this patient but then it goes
beyond a troponin elevation in an ACS
patient has also its implication for
Wisc for what is the prognosis of this
patient and we have learned over the
years that an increased troponin is is
correlated to the short term in
long-term prognosis of the patient we
have implications for 30 days in regards
of risk of death in them I those 30-day
risk are very important to consider as
we are looking at rehospitalization
rates which are a critical metrics for
clinical performance in today's
environment so identifying those
patients who are at elevated risk here
is very important that we capture them
all but then we need to also look at the
clinical implications how do we treat
those patients identifying patients at
high risk is not the only thing but then
also it is the question of what are we
going to do with the patient now this is
an old
concept this is a traditional concept I
shouldn't say hope it's a traditional
concept and my point here why I'm
bringing this one up it is important to
understand then as we are discussing the
universal definition of MI as we are
discussing the 99th percentile as the
critical threshold as the lowest
threshold we have had in the many years
of troponin that this threshold has not
been evaluated as it relates to risk
stratification but more importantly to
the clinical implications to the
questions of what are we doing with the
patients
this is emphasized in the most recent
management guideline for announced Emmys
and unstable angina where the guidelines
do make the important statement that the
implications of the universal definition
of MI with the use of the 99th
percentile have not been explored fully
in regards of implications of what we
should do with the patient should be
intensify all the options we have should
we send all the patients into the cath
labs those implications have been
explored with previous versions of
proponents with higher thresholds so
that is an important concept now let
allow me a brief time to look at risk
stratification in acs patients and I
have here in this next slide with
stratification for ACS patients 30 days
risk of death and MI in booster for the
point I'm trying to make here is when
I'm looking at the risk of death or
and/or MI and I'm looking at the
different thresholds of in this case
troponin t I what I see here is is
really that we have non-detectable
components on the very left and then L
component elevations on the three right
groups of bars when we have note
elevations in this setting we have a
baseline risk baseline risk for death
and the baseline risk for we unfortunate
now see questions are coming in and
which reminds me also you can ask
questions and type them into your system
but I will wait until later towards the
end until I will start responding to
those questions so I have to ask you for
a little bit of patience baseline risk
on the very left side with undetectable
troponin T's as we are now looking in
this range in this second group
detectable troponin levels 0.01 to 0.03
which is a 10% CV of the troponin T
currently commercially available in the
market we do have a group of patients in
this range between detectable and 10%
who do have an increased risk now for
death and who do have an increased risk
for reinforcing as the threshold moves
further up between point zero three and
point one which is the who cut out again
risk increases and as then the
thresholds are clearly within the WHO
this traditional cutoff range
there is another increase in risk for
death the risk for M I is not further
increasing because those patients have
been treated in those treatments you can
see the impact of treatment the message
here is as we are moving stepwise
through the different possibilities of
thresholds any release builds
incremental or provides incremental risk
for the patient's already within 30 days
and then what are the clinical
implications and they have been examined
by the tactics see me 18 trial many
years ago the key point of this trial
was they looked at patients where either
a non STEMI or unstable angina and they
compared to therapeutic options invasive
therapy and non-invasive therapy and
what was interesting in the
although it was an overall positive
trial where invasive therapy had a
better impact showed better outcomes in
patient the benefit of really the
invasive therapy was clearly limited to
those patients with detectable
components here in this case with
troponin any troponin elevations above
the detectable level of 0.01 a nanogram
per milliliter this benefit was not
observed in the troponin negative
patients so here we see already a
possibility if we have an ACS patient a
clear ACS patient and they do have a
troponin T elevation this patient
benefits from the cath lab and is
observing or has a benefit of 50%
reduction in depth am I at the thirty
Bay timeframe not so in the troponin
negative setting so that is another area
where we do have really this connection
between here an ACS patient who has a
measurable troponin they do have a
benefit from a more aggressive therapy
even from the most aggressive one which
we have with the invasive therapy
sending the patient to the cath lab with
the intent to treat in case blockage is
found but I want to also clearly
emphasize another point which is again
we are not treating a patient based on
their troponin but we are treating the
patient in context of the clinical
setting and that the question of the
therapeutic options are really in
clinical context so it is the global
risk assessment which is important
rather than just a single marker in
general just to clarify that I avoid
misunderstandings that we are treating
lab numbers those numbers have to be
interpreted in clinical context but now
as I mentioned before as we are looking
at the universal definition
of MI and the use of the 99th percentile
we still require more data to really
understand the implications on do we
have incremental risk very likely we do
have based on some first publications
but what should we do then in this
setting in regards of how should we
treat those patients again the with the
universal definition of mi for example
we are finding those patients with
troponin elevations who have a type 2
myocardial infarction and a lot of those
type 2 a myocardial infarction should
not go to the cath lab should not be
treated type 2 M eyes are very likely
more frequent in women and we do know
that not that all women needed to be
sent to the cath lab so again we need to
be aware as we are dealing with the 99th
percentile we need to really look for
data to help us further to decide what
the role of troponin is as we are
intensifying therapy and let me also
emphasize this year very clearly
especially since I'm presented from
world's diagnostic I need to make those
statements which can be different from
many experts who are practicing medicine
in the fear the practicing physician our
experts our Kol can make different
recommendations based on their clinical
experience as a Roche representative I
need to focus on what data is available
and my reference about the clinical
implications is that there if if there
is data it is very limited what we have
available so we need to be careful about
those areas so what are the challenges
for future cardiac assays and those have
been described by dr. Apple very nicely
he mentions here for example that with
high sensitivity assays we do get more
precision at lower concentration the
measuring range is gone very low - now
one nanogram per liter or 1 picogram
permit earlier so this is we are seeing
numbers the measuring range or the
reported units are changing for high
sensitivity assays we will not see the
point 0 some number but we will see
picograms but what we do need to keep in
mind is we also don't have fda-approved
high sensitivity as is available in the
market because we are still trying to
understand what is the difference
between the web optimized cutoff as we
are starting to use the 99th percentile
we need to really make sure that there
is enough accuracy at the 99th
percentile and we have to clearly find
the understanding so that the clinical
understanding in clinical practice so
that we minimize really false positives
findings or misinterpretations of
troponin in clinical setting there is a
proposal from dr. Apple about how do we
define sensitivity and that has been
published in his scorecard which is
gaining more and more acceptance among
experts in his scorecard he clearly
looks at precision at the 99th
percentile here again the guideline
acceptable less than 10% to be
clinically usable if the precision is
greater than 10% but less than 20% and
not acceptable when it's greater than
20% now as we are looking at now
sensitivity here in context of how many
of the normal reference population do
have a detectable troponin with a given
a say we have contemporary assays which
detect within the normal population less
than 50% of them with a detectable
troponin if we are then moving to high
sensitivity assays this this portion of
how
patience how many of normal of the
reference population do have measurable
opponents but the most sensitive test we
can have up to 95 percent of the normal
population having measurable components
now translating this into clinical
practice we clearly see also here the
potential for confusion because all
those patients now we can imagine that
we have a lot of our patients coming
into the emergency room who have a
problem have now a measurable troponin
and there is this hesitation of what
this this means it has fog gnostic
implications long term but for the
interpretation whether or not this
patient has an MI again education is
here required reminding again as to this
graph here where the sensitivity now
goes down so far that we clearly can
differentiate between disease and non
disease but the troponin levels can be
measured in the normal range if we are
mu measuring up to 50% we are talking
contemporary assays if we are measuring
up to almost up to 95% we are talking
the highest sensitivity SS now from here
I will make some closing remarks and
really emphasize again that the
standards for clinical laboratory
operations is is really important what
what we call them what what do we call
the different components that we are
specific what we really mean how do we
understand the designation of high
sensitivity assays what is also very
important is as we are looking at the
reference population is how are we
determined the 99th percentile are we
determining it by looking at patients
with no underlying cardiovascular
disease
or are we looking at patients
hospitalized patients
example we do not have an MI the 99th
percentile would be a completely
different there is not a final
conclusion about what those criteria
should be to determine the appropriate
99th percentile although there is a
clear tendency to look at not really at
patients with underlying cardiovascular
disease here but the final work has not
really been said we might see a cut-off
gender-specific we might see an impact
of aging we need to clearly
differentiate acceptable imprecision
absolute versus relative changes what is
more important needs to be considered
there are some publications out there
for the more sensitive tests
differentiating clearly between acute
and chronic elevations they're having
analytical and biological variability in
mind and and so forth so all those
criterias need to be considered as we
are moving into the future so then men
proponents have not are no longer
specific only for MI they the troponin
elevation has an implication of what is
suspected with the patient if I have a
high-risk patient there is a high
susceptibility for MI if I have a
low-risk patient a different story again
that refers to the pretest probability a
troponin is also recommended and can be
used in CKD patients again here we are
looking at especially a change in
troponin over time and then we have
ready to anticipate as we are
encountering more non ischemic
conditions which can have troponin
elevations routine troponin testing is
not recommended for those kind of
conditions so those are
important considerations and then
finally we really need to reflect that
troponin elevations outside ACS are not
uncommon they still mean cardiac often
mean cardiac myocyte ear injury and we
have those conditions being listed and
as we are looking at troponin elevations
in non ACS environment there are
probably Gnostic they are not false
positives and they have implications of
for the future for the future disease
progression of this patient now in
conclusion we need to remember that
troponin is only one piece of the puzzle
and we clearly have to interpret those
troponin results in clinical context and
with those words I now will go to
questions and answers and if you can
have more questions please feel free to
type them in there my first question I
have here and it's a longer one I have
to see if I can expand it just with me
can I get help I see okay sorry I was
looking at the wrong part the question
is can you please expand in your second
point of where stratification with very
independent Association as opposed to
patients with disease okay and let me
eventually step back what I was
referring to as we have ACS patients in
ACS patients we clearly have each
incremental troponin elevations is
representing for incremental risk
short-term risk of MI and death this is
different from
the chronic elevation the koala chronic
elevation doesn't have this change over
time but still if I do have a chronic
elevation and in one patient I have a
chronic elevation which is lower than in
the second patient the patient who has
the higher chronic elevation is is at an
increased risk for a future event is at
an increased risk for future death which
means also here the level of troponin
elevation is giving me information but
they are definitely long-term and there
are always meaning a higher troponin
elevation gives higher risk then if
there is a lower elevation I hope that
this clears it up another question is
that my second question is is there any
need to continue ck-mb testing in
routine community hospital laboratory
for the use of detecting we invert
interesting question when we are looking
at really I should say there is a
preference for some people to still use
C a and B especially for really
unfortunate but troponin does to a good
job and there are publications
especially from Mayo dr. singer
published around this where there is
really no need for ck-mb the guidelines
are also emphasizing that troponin is
the gold standard and I'm aware of many
institutions who made it we eliminate it
ck-mb from their tests they are ordering
from tests they are offering making it
more difficult for physicians to order
this test which are all an indication
that if you really look at with use in
the complexity in what you are dealing
with that the relevance of CK and B is
today not there anymore
even in case of we and fortune we still
would have time for more questions so I
will give it few moments so as I don't
see any more questions in I would like
to thank the audience for your
participation really appreciate this on
a Friday afternoon or depending on where
you are on the globe I have seen that we
have some international dialing where it
is now at night appreciate your time
appreciate the opportunity for
presenting to you thank you very much
for your time and have a great weekend
thank you very much